-
Micaela Bain, à Washington.
- Pour avoir le droit de porter
une arme à feu en public dans
l'État de New York, un citoyen
d d d démontrer qu'il avait
une raison valable de croire
qu'il faisait face à une menace
concrète ou qu'il était g g g g.
Or, dans un décision rendue
à 6 contre 3, la Cour suprême
des États-Unis a décrété quecet.
Le juge Clarence Thomas,
qui a rédigé la décision de
la majorité, écrit: "Le deuxième
et le quatorzième amendement
de la Constitution protègent
le droit d'un individu
d'avoir en sa possession
une arme à feu pour se défendre
dans les lieux publics."
La vice-présidente américaine
affirme que le président Biden
et elle sont profondément
inquiets et troublés.
"Cela va à l'encontre du
bon sens et de la Constitution
des États-Unis."
Le maire de New York
parle d'une Cour suprême
déconnectée de la réalité.
"Nous ne pouvons pas
permettre que New York
devienne un Far West", dit-il.
La gouverneure démocrate de
l'État ne cache pas sa colère.
"Cette décision est
non seulement irresponsable,
mais répréhensible", affirme
Kathy Hochul. "Ce n'est pas ce
que veulent les New-Yorkais."
"Clairement, nous sommes face
à une Cour suprême militante
de droite", croit Kirsten
Gillibrand, sénatrice démocrate
de l'État de New York.
"C'est dangereux",
dit cette New-Yorkaise.
"Aucun autre pays ne fait ça",
ajoute celle-ci.
"Ça n'a aucun sens!"
D'autres, comme
ce sénateur républicain,
parlent d'une grande victoire.
Ailleurs au pays, cinq autres
États et le District de Columbia
imposent aussi des restrictions
discrétionnaires sur le port
d'arme en public.
Cette décision tombe
à un moment où une majorité
d'Américains réclament un plus
grand contrôle des armes à feu
et que les sénateurs,
démocrates et républicains,
s'entendent pour adopter
une loi restreignant l'accès
aux armes. Une première
en presque 30 ans
et qui, malgré tout,
ne mettra pas fin au débat.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canada, Washingto